This video is brought to you by Squarespace,
from websites and online stores to marketing tools and analytics.
Squarespace is the all in one platform to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business.
Check out Squarespace three doesn't link to the description below more on that
Towards the middle of the 14th century,
a terrible plague struck at the people of the East and the West.
It crudely mistreated the nations.
It carried away a great part of that generation.
It swept away and destroyed the most beautiful achievements of civilization.
It shattered the forces vampires,
snuffed their vigor weakened that power to the point of total destruction.
It was as if the voice of nature and then ordered the world to humble
itself. And the weld had a bait.
These words were written in 1377 by Tunisian scholar and historian
[inaudible].
He was talking about the single greatest catastrophe in the history of mankind.
Up until that point, the black death, which reached North Africa in Europe,
in the 1340s,
but even Caledonia was not referring exclusively to that pandemic
modern accounts of the black death usually focus on the first wave,
but rarely cover it's returned to the shores of the old world,
but only a decade after the initial outbreak inhabitants of Europe and the
Mediterranean basin would again,
suffer from a second sweep of the grim angel. This time,
the more innocent would fall.
The black death that redox became known as the plague of children.
[Inaudible].
Death is the name we give to date to the pandemic,
which killed between one third and two thirds of the world's population.
The first half of the 14th century,
the epidemic likely originated in central Asia or in China in the early 1330s.
It then spread to Europe,
the Mediterranean and Africa carried by caravans of merchants along the silk
road, as well as Bango cavalry by September of 1347,
the black death appeared in Southern Italy as an uninvited guest on merchant
ships. From that traveling mostly by sea,
this mysterious disease conquered most of Europe and Africa eventually subsiding
in the early 1350s. When I say mysterious, I mean,
from the points of view of witnesses of that time, contemporary historians,
archeologists and medical professionals identify the most likely culprits.
The black death was an extremely virulent and infectious pandemic of bubonic and
pneumonic plague caused by a bacterium called Yesenia pestos or
Y pestis. The bacteria used fleas as vectors,
which in turn traveled on the fairway of rats and other rodents after infecting
and killing their animal hosts, the fleas would attack humans.
If you want to know more about the black death,
you can absolutely watch our biographic special back from Halloween last year,
2019 today, though,
we're going to focus on the period immediately after the pestilence of 1347 and
especially about the so-called second play go second pestilence or
the plague of children. This was the second outbreak,
which ravaged Europe from 1360 to 1364.
And I will take the occasion to review and contrast some theories,
which argue that these epidemics were not playing outbreaks and that why pestos
and its complimentary fleas and ramps were innocence,
but let's stick to the criminal logy of events for the moments in the early
1350s, the black death had finally given some rest bites to Europe,
most souls are swept away by the normal occurrences,
Vieira famine endemic disease.
The hundred years war the on the scene angel of death has laid down its broom
for the moment. But what type of society has arisen after the catastrophe,
as I mentioned,
as much as two thirds of the population has died in an agony of fevers and
swollen black boobos, this men's fields and farms were empty.
Some of the remaining survivors in the countryside abandons their dwellings and
to move to the cities, looking for a fresh start.
They were also looking to enjoy the benefits offered by city authorities,
seeking to replenish their numbers.
Municipal leaders were keen to attract new residents.
Other survivors decided to remain in the countryside.
Labor was now SCAs and peasants and farm tenants could now negotiate higher
wages and lower rents.
The demographics of landowners have also changed within Tanya families wiped out
large plots of lands were left without anybody to inherit them,
except for them church,
which used the aftermath of the blank death to greatly increase its properties,
wealth and power.
Another consequence of the black death was a downshift in the nature of warfare.
There were a few men of fighting age, and especially if you are peasants,
that could be levied to raise armies. So in the 1350s,
feudal Lords and monarchs had to rely more and more on companies of mercenaries.
These were private armies traveling frequently,
either shifting theater of operations or simply switching sides.
It can be argued that large numbers of traveling soldiers in unsanitary
conditions may be a recipe for a pestilence disaster,
but in the first half of the 1350s, no new epidemics were recorded in Europe.
Well,
except for one of an unconventional sought an outbreak of marriages take the
French town of shivery,
130 kilometers North of neon shivery was the hardest by the black death in 1348,
the town registers acknowledged zero marriages taking place that yet,
but in 1349, 42 lucky couples sealed their vows.
A similar situation was described in Britain by historian, JC Russell.
He argues that the black death in Britain killed only 20% of those aged between
10 to 35, but exacted a much higher toll amongst the parents.
So the younger generations having now inherited and it's become financially
independent.
We're all too eager to marry a spike in marriages naturally led to an increase
in birth rates. One could even say that humanity was bouncing back. Well,
that nature was trying to compensate for the tremendous losses that the human
race had suffered. I know that life in the late middle ages, wasn't a picnic,
especially if you were French or English, slugging it out for decades.
On end the aftermath of the black death.
They must've felt like a relief after years and years of pain. Finally,
the giggles of children and nursery rhymes would fill the app, but alas,
it wouldn't look.
[Inaudible].
The black death of 1347 had launched lead sped,
the lands of Bohemia and Southern Poland during its March of conquest.
In 1352,
the play could reach the vast lands of Russia before apparently subsume leading
in a way death had returned home after starting its journey in central Asia,
five years later,
the disease popped up again in 1357 records show that a second pestilence had
reached Prague ravaging the city over the course of several outbreaks that lost
it until 1368 and 1359.
Evidence shows that the play you could cross into modern day Germany with cases
recorded in the city of [inaudible] in the region of suedey.
The contagion cuts through Germany from East to West and crossed the Rhine into
the kingdom of France. In 1360,
the epidemic could reach the Fest city of Avignon in Southern France,
which had served as the residents of the paper seasons 35. As you may imagine,
such an important city was teaming with clergymen bishops, Aras to craps,
and the best physicians that money could buy. One of them was Dr. Guida,
Shirley ACC,
who left a precious testimony of his experience with the second play gins,
the atmosphere of despair and paranoia that gripped his fellow citizens.
It reads many were in doubt about the cause of this great mortality.
In some places, they thought that the Jews had poisoned the world.
And so they killed them in others that it was the poor deformed and they drove
the mouse and others that it was the Nobles and they fit to go abroad.
The lynching of Jewish communities was unfortunately an all too common
by-product of this pandemic as well as 1347 outbreak.
Even the Pope had called for Christians not to slay their fellow Jewish
citizens, but senseless death breeds panic in turn, panic breeds,
violence and violent crowds need a scapegoat.
Jewish communities were perceived to suffer fewer deaths than Christian ones.
And so it was easy to blame them as the cause of the plague.
These acts of violence when recorded could be used by historians to trace the
progress of the contagion. For example, a French authors, John Glenn,
his song was able to determine that the second play could reach Poland in 1630
after finding Jewish eulogies,
commemorating the slang of martyrs and crack out Dennis Dolan,
competitive for the ponies records with writings by just Shirley acted after
your, and they all highlight the same conclusion,
the second pestilence reaped victims across the societal spectrum,
but it had a predilection for certain profiles of victims. Young men.
I have a women as members of the upper classes over the lower classes,
but most of all, we're child victims, age 13 or younger.
These were the children who had been born after the black death had disappeared
who were now being struck down by this new plague.
What would it have been like to be a parents in those days, consider this.
You have survived the single deadliest event in the history of humanity.
You have risen from despair and found the strength to start a new life and to
create new life. And only a few years later,
that same invisible monster who was killed half of those you ever knew and never
loved while that monster returns and kills the young person.
Who's now given new meaning to your existence.
One year after the doctor to show Leanne had recorded his findings,
the plague had reached Paris. It was the summer of 1361. Here.
Chronicle has confirmed that children died by the thousands,
but they also noted that the illness guilds scores of young men in the late
teens, early twenties, but sped their young lives.
They described how the streets of Paris,
half emptied were strewn by silent shadows,
gliding away with our eyes lowered to the grounds of city of widows platinum
black. You have started to spot a pattern here, Bohemia, Poland, young men,
children, even the upper classes, areas and populations, which had been spared.
The ordeal of the 1347 panic were now succumbing to the second
plague.
This trend was confirmed by the pattern of contagion in the Italian peninsula.
Now, just before we continue with today's video,
I think it's time we take a little breather, take a little break.
This one's pretty intense.
And I want to tell you about today's sponsor Squarespace. Now,
two simple things.
Maybe you've got an idea for a website or a business that you'll want to stop us
and you know, just knocking around there and your minds. Well,
to the only way to figure out whether that business is worth pursuing is to get
it out there into the world.
And I know this can be a little bit scary because it's always scary to go and
try new things. But knowing how to set up a website is not an excuse.
And there are no excuses available with Squarespace.
Squarespace allows you to create a powerful website, whatever you're up to.
I want to sell something online. Yes. Set up a store. You want to do a podcast?
Absolutely. Totally can do that as well.
Now it all starts on Squarespace with a beautiful template that you can
customize to your heart's content or start from scratch or move over from
an existing domain. But take my advice just even on their beautiful templates,
you'll look at them. You'll be like, well,
I couldn't design anything that looks not good. So let's just use that.
And once you've got it up and running, there's no tech BS to deal with.
There's no updates, patches, stuff like that.
You didn't have to worry about that.
Also Squarespace sounds a little of the website stuff, podcasts, like I said,
maintenance, social integrations, all that stuff.
Plus they have 24 seven support. So out's fantastic. I mean, honestly,
you're probably not going to get stuck. It's pretty easy. But if you do like,
hi Squarespace, I need some help and they will help.
You have to squarespace.com for a free trial.
And when you're ready to launch go to squarespace.com forward slash biographics
to save 10% off your first purchase of a website or a domain
In 1362 and 1363,
the second pestilence crossed the Alps and made its returned to Italy areas that
had survived. The first pestilence, largely unscathed went out, punished by the,
of the new contagion. In this case,
the target was Milan city authorities that successfully protected that
population by enforcing a strict quarantine in 1348.
But now they were taken by surprise from Milan and Lombardi,
the plague spread to the East and the Venetia region.
And then Southwoods reaching PR sends us some 70 miles Southeast of Milan
here and unnamed chronic Allah left a vivid description of the outward signs of
the second pestilence in some of the dying and excretion coagulated in the
boobos under the armpits or on the groin in others,
postulates or abscesses formed around the heads, especially behind the years,
others yet spat a putrid blood, which was a very bad sign, a burning fever,
suffocated all of them after two or three days of manifesting.
Our friends in PSN also explains how he have survived in patients who had
developed a is on the groin.
If those tumors became softer and the fever diminished,
if the bubo was covered in plaster of lawns and more of,
and then lost with a hot iron and depleted of secretions,
then the patient was healed. This description is just one of the many kills,
which circulated at the time,
the most widely reprinted was a treatise written by I,
the Bishop of ALCL Dr. A physique. In other words,
the Bishop of all hosts in Denmark who claimed to have studied medicine at
Montpellier university or announced center of medieval medical studies,
fun facts,
two centuries later Montpellier would be the Alma mater of another famous plague
doctor in profit.
Michelle did not tra Don AKA Nostradamus since we have a video profile all about
him as well. So if you want to check that out,
please do the Bishop believe that the disease was propagated by venomous humors,
which entered the victims, outweighs burden this from happening.
He recommended holding a loaf of bread or a sponge soaked in vinegar next to
one's mouth, all egg things stop in the way of humans.
He taught to look out for signs of warning,
which may alert to the incoming pestilence. These aren't swarms of flies,
shooting stars, comments, thunder,
and lightening coming from the South and Southern the wins
or vapors could be generated by any factor which may corrupt the app,
the dead carrion, still waters in a ditch, or even a privy AKA toilet.
These vapors may poison either the air or the grounds when both elements are
corrupted and infirmity is caused in man,
the formidable physician explains why some people fall ill while others are
immune. According to him,
bodies that are more hot disposed will be an easy prey to contagion by hot
disposed humans. People whose poles were more open than normal.
This happens if they had an angry temper,
if they engaged in hauling physical labor, if they bathe too often,
or if they abuse themselves with women,
the Bishop addresses the question of person to person contagion.
While the primary infection may be caused by humans,
a diseased individual will develop boils and sores,
which in turn will release toxic vapors infecting bystanders.
Now we may have gotten the causes all wrong,
but he nails this next piece of advice and pestilence time,
nobody should stand in great press of people because some man of them may be.
In fact, also in the time of the pestilence,
it is better to abide within the house for it is not wholesome to go into the
city or town to get rid of vapors infected individuals should change the
chamber. They sleep in and have their windows open to the North and East,
but never to the South. And why not to the South? Well, because hot winds.
Open the pores, of course.
As an added precaution against contagion households were encouraged to purify
the ad by spraying vinegar and Rose water or by burning hubs, such as Bay tree,
Juniper, wormwood, and something called this, which I've never heard of.
And it's not going to be in my pronunciation, diction rape.
When it comes to curing the infected,
the Bishop's advice was to bleed the patients until they fainted for a little
lessening of blood moveth or stare at the venom.
Clearly neither the lens advice from ahas, nor from the writer,
PSN could work for all of those affected the plague,
took another leap in a southeasterly direction, reaching Balone yet here,
the contagion was stubborn and unforgiving.
The first cases were recorded as early as January, 1362.
And the citizens of this fast city continued to die for the next 13 months while
I belong here was systematically decimated.
The speed of travel for the second black death seemed to have slowed down,
but it was only a temporary response in 1363, death moved to Tuscany,
then central Italy by June incidental, Naples,
its gateway to the rest of Southern Italy.
When death kicked open the door to Naples have completed its invasion of the
major port cities of the Mediterranean basin,
traveling merchants and sailors were efficient vectors of the plague, Barcelona,
Crete, Damascus monk, other port cities to endure the cruel call.
The generalized mortality appear to subside in Italy only in mid 1364,
although it continued to haunt the canals of Venice for much longer Italian
Chronicles and historians have observed an interesting point about the timing
aspect of the second plague.
It killed about as quickly as the first one after about five days from the
appearance of the first signs,
but its geographic spread was much slower compared to the original black death.
The pandemic had blazed through the peninsula South to North in 10 months.
The second one instead had lingered on for almost three years,
taking its times and they ruined a depleted populations before marching on to
another location.
The slower spread may be explained by the more selective nature of the killer in
1361.
Most European Chronicle is agree on the point that children and young men were
the favorite victims of this plague.
Young men especially were more physically mobile by killing them.
The pathogens also reduce their own chances to travel as low as spreads.
However did not prevent the plague of children from reaching all the corners of
the continent. Our next destination will be Britain. Well,
we'll take a look at the detailed records left by the bishops of Winchester.
Yeah.
We'll tax the public crony on tells us how the second play outbreak began in
London during Easter of 1361 and then moved to invade the rest of Southern
England like in France,
Italy or Poland is the pestilence laid waste among children,
young men and the wealthier rungs of society.
Whereas Nobles in clergymen had Indiana mortality rates of 4.5% in 1348 and
13% in 1349,
nearly 24% of the upper classes were killed by the fire bu-bye is in 1361,
but when it comes to the general death rates,
all Chronicles and records agree that it was not as high as the one experience
during the black death.
Approximately one quarter of the population died during the second plague,
which is still a horrifying figure out of context,
but might be the less than half the figure for many, a decade earlier. However,
the second plagues impact on society was equally devastating. If not more.
So the population had not fully recovered yet.
It was subjected to a second call.
The demise of the more innocent victims had a profound effect on the morale of
those who were left behind the waste laid by the second plate in Britain is
generally well-documented.
But the records held in the diocese of Winchester offer a particularly detailed
pictures.
We have learned from an excellent paper by John Mullen of Cardiff university,
the bishops of Winchester oversaw 60 manners spread over a large area,
which included six counties.
The records left behind by the diocese gave a detailed accounts of the
demographics of the outbreak during the 1348 black death.
The Winchester lambs that suffered a death rate of 48.8%.
One of the highest in the British Isles,
but [inaudible] had been launched really SPAD but in 1361, priests,
Abbots and nuns were not so lucky around 30% of them died despite having a
generally better diet and living conditions than the majority of the populace.
By looking at the inheritance deeds recorded in the six counties under the
Bishop,
John Mullen was able to confirm that the second plague had a predilection for
male victims in 1349, almost 68% of all ads were mailed.
This was in line with previously recorded trends and with customers of the age
skipped to 1361. And now the majority of as well women,
61% and among them widows had the relative majority.
This tells us that most of the victims were probably men in their twenties or
thirties whose children were too young to inherit.
So even more likely whose children had been taken away by the great leveler
who did not calf young age or innocence,
the plague of children did not take long before it spread across Wales,
Northern England and Scotland in manners, across Britain,
inheritance deeds and tax accounts provide a consistent picture of which
demographics succumbed and which survived. But beyond them in numbers,
we would like to remember also the words of poets who were confronted with death
Welsh poet, Llewellyn,
fie Han recorded his experiences in 1363 and a poem haint E noodle,
which would be translated as the infection of the nodes.
The Whelan left us some vivid descriptions of the [inaudible] versus filled with
hatred for an incomprehensible enemy to him.
These swellings were like the pommel of a sword of Swift strife and the shape of
an Apple and full of pain. They were the bitter head of an odious onion,
a little boil, which spares no one's smoldering like a red hot, cold,
a tiny thing, which about man's end. The poets survived the pandemic,
but his four children were not so lucky. Morford was taken fair DAF.
It was taken you and everyone's Gerry favorite was taken with an unceasing.
The men's was taken and I was left feeling betrayed and stunned,
barely alive in a harsh world, a harsh world, indeed.
The second pestilence eventually waned down,
but the plague never really left Europe alone returning for wave after wave.
The disease returned in 1374 and then in 1383, 30, 90,
and 1400, every subsequent wave was overall less deadly than the previous one.
And I stress overall here. The total number of victims declined each time.
But out of the total,
the proportion of children involved increased statistics from burial places in
Tuscany show. That's in 1383,
88% of the plague victims were age 12 or younger.
The true slaughter of the innocence following outbreaks appeared to be less
cruel against children,
but their combined efforts caused a lasting decline in the population of Europe,
which recovered to pre at 1348 levels,
only one and a half centuries later in the 1520s.
[Inaudible].
The profound demographic change brought a balanced bite,
the plane cause lasting effects on the makeup of society. These were changes,
which again were well-documented in England and may apply also to other parts of
Europe. According to a story in column plats,
the toll exacted on young males caused a widespread shortage of labor allowing
for more women to enter the workforce.
Now we also know that more women have become inheritors of wealth.
The combined effect was that more women had become financially independent,
which meant that they either decided to marry later or not marry at all leading
to a decline in births.
The shortage of labor also led to an increase in wages and an abundance of cheap
land. As many plots were now abandoned.
This meant that those couples who did marry what less motivated to have children
in the middle ages, if you work to the lands and increase in children,
mens an increase in cheap labor, but this was not a requirement anymore.
Now that wealthier couples that access to cheaper land and other consequences of
the labor shortage was a change in diet and pre play gears.
Most land was used to grow cereals after the second pestilence,
most arable plots were converted into Woodlands and pastures,
which are less labor intensive. The typical Dodd for peasants and farmers,
which used to be cereal,
heavy changed to incorporate more meat and dairy products.
The subsequent waves of the plague also impacted the traditional feudal
relationship between the peasants and the aristocratic landlords before the
plague,
peasants were more accurately described as serfs and paid rent to the local Lord
in cash, farm products and labor.
They had to ask permission if the daughter wanted to marry a stranger from
another village,
they had to pay Harriet's special taxes upon the death of a household member.
But by the end of the 14th century,
those serfs had morphed into either small landowners themselves or free tenants
free of most previous obligations except to pay a more reasonable rent in cash.
The ruling class is obviously trying to resist these changes by imposing laws
and does establishing a status go antsy after the plagues. However,
these were unpopular reforms that eventually sparked the peasant revolt of 1381,
which was led by legendary leader. What Tyler? Well, that's a story for another.
Studies.
The effects of the plague of children and subsequent waves raised some questions
on the nature of the disease was the black death,
actually an epidemic of bubonic plague caused by their sending up pestis
bacteria.
The implication of increased child mortality was the survival of older adults.
So you had been exposed to previous epidemics. This suggests a quad immunity,
according to professor Samuel cone of Glasgow university among others.
This is not a characteristic of the bubonic plague in the 19th and 20th century.
A pandemic of plague caused by Yesenia pestos spread from Hong Kong to China and
India. Then to most coastal cities around the world, medical professionals,
both then and now were able to observe the populations could be hit by returning
waves of Yesenia and still suffer from the plague. In other words,
they couldn't develop an immunity. Strangely enough,
rats actually could develop a resistance which eventually lowered infection
rates. Speaking of ramps that most common parasites or fleas in theory,
these fleas were vectors for the plague bacteria.
Y pestis they thrive during periods of malt climates like spring and autumn
while they become inactive in summer and winds up this seasonal pass.
And it should influence patterns of contagion movements,
but both the black death.
And the second plague did not follow these pattern and remained evenly lethal
throughout the year.
Another piece of evidence against bubonic plague is that medieval Chronicle is
never mentioned rats.
The modern plague pandemic demonstrated how human contagion is usually proceeded
by large die-offs of rats and how rodents scurry out into the open in great
numbers before dying.
None of this is described during accounts from the 14th century critics of the
bubonic plague hypothesis,
speculates that the black death and subsequent pandemics were caused by another
disease. Maybe it was typhus or smallpox or even the flu.
Maybe it was a yet unknown illness supporters of team bubo defends their
pathogen of choice.
By claiming that white pestis may have been spread by other parasites,
aside from the fleas, perhaps it was spread by human license.
If medieval writers did not mention rats,
this was because those rodents were so commonplace that there wasn't any reason
to include them in that works would a contemporary blogger from London spent any
time writing about pigeons in Trafalgar square proponents of the bubonic plague
theory can call upon archeology to support their claims. In March of 2020,
a mass burial of at least 48 individuals was Exuma now,
medieval monastery and Lincoln share in the UK,
the presence of coins with the image of King ed with the thirds and radiocarbon
analysis helps date these bodies as having died between 1327 and
1377 in the tooth, Paul put one bodies molar,
the archeology team of professor Hugh Wilmer has found DNA sequences that match
those of the pathogen that killed those poles souls. And yup.
It was Yesenia pestos. So you might think case closed, right? Well,
not necessarily traces of why pestos have been found in medieval mass graves
since at least 2002, but in many cases,
contamination and his methodology floors have invalidated the results.
Regardless. There remains a central question to be answered.
If recent outbreaks of people like plague did not generate immunity.
Why did this happen during the plague of children and the later waves and MIT
paper from 2007 may have found the answer.
Maybe the medieval plague was a different strain of Y pestis in conjunction with
a secondary infection that has yet to be identified for our past.
We're not scientists. So we can't give you a definitive answer.
We can say for sure was that it wasn't caused by the G five.
So I really haven't found that video. Interesting. If you did,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to check it off and
testing sponsor for this episode. Squarespace.
Thank you for watching.